this program is brought to you by Emory
University good afternoon everyone
welcome to the third in a three-part
series entitled creating retirement my
name is NaN part 'let and i'm the
director of the emeritus college and it
is the emeritus college which is
sponsoring these events i'm glad to see
so many familiar faces and also to
welcome newcomers today we have in our
midst several members or more than
several quite a few members of the
emeritus college and i wish that you
would raise your hands just so we can
know who you are members of the emeritus
college good thank you i am going to
volunteer them actually I haven't asked
but I'm going to just do it if you have
questions about transitions to
retirement I'm guessing that these folks
would be more than willing to talk about
their own experiences in retirement I
want to draw your attention to several
items today that you have in front of
you on your desk we have packets for you
which include for today's session
creating or financial planning for a
Creative retirement I especially like
the graphic and I think charity crabtree
who created it can't hear me but I like
this graphic we have you know money
growing on a tree now it is a bonsai
tree so I'm not quite sure what what
that symbolism is all about but in any
case we're going to talk about our
speaker is going to talk to you about
financial matters in this whole concept
of creating retirement we have copies
also of former the two former sessions
and those are available for you at the
registration desk
so if you missed session one or two and
we'd like to have that please pick up a
packet as you as you leave I'm going to
direct you back again to the money tree
and also to ask you to be sure to notice
our steering committee who is listed
here and I'm going to name these
individuals and some of these are folks
are here with us today and if you would
when I call your name if you just stand
for a moment so we can thank you for the
considerable work and acknowledge the
considerable work that you've done we
have Bob jahan whose chair of the
steering committee and candler professor
of cell biology emeritus Joanne Dalton
committee member professor of Nursing
America Robin DeAndre professor of
orthopaedic surgery emeritus Ron Frank
dean emeritus of ghosts wetta Business
School and candler professor of
marketing and rod hunter who's not here
today who is professor of pastoral
theology emeritus so my thanks to all of
you for your time and your effort and
the thought that you've put into this
the final thing I want to point out to
you in the packet is the evaluation form
and it's bright pink so please take time
to complete this for us and in doing so
you're really helping us to serve you
better in the future without further ado
I want to introduce again our steering
committee member Ron Frank Dean of the
business school and active member of the
emeritus college and Ron will in turn
introduce our speaker for today thank
you so much
Roger Ward is a partner in the wealth
management firm of Tarpley and Underwood
he joined the foam about 13 years ago
previously he worked in the Atlanta
office of Deloitte & Touche and served
as the controller for savannah-chatham
Board of Education he's been involved in
many professional groups including the
personal financial planning section of
the aicpa and the estate and financial
planning section of the Georgia Society
of CPAs he's also served as an adjunct
faculty member for the department of
risk management and insurance at Georgia
State teaching a course in personal
financial planning he's a Masters of
Science in personal financial planning a
licensed CPA earned his designation is
of personal financial specialist lives
in Roswell member of the Roswell method
at United Methodist Church his wife
lolly and he have a son and daughter now
in case you've got a stereotype of the
cpa types I my wife isn't here today so
I can make that crack she's a CPA being
conservative and these financial planner
is being conservative I should tell you
that he and his wife lolly took six
months off and backpack the Pacific Rim
Nepal China Indonesia got that right at
Hunter spent a little time in Singapore
got to the right place oh yes before I
turn the podium over at truth in
advertising compels me to say that
Tarpley and under would have done our
taxes since we came here in 1990 the
firm itself started in 1987 and
subsequently have helped us in financial
planning and the like we did our first
financial plans I'm a zealot on this
subject 40 years ago I'm 77 I think the
best favor you can do for loved ones
that are younger than you is encourage
them to do their first round of
financial planning the earlier you do it
the more wiggle room you've got you're
fortunate if things turn out better a
little difficult if things turn out
worse and they never turn out the way
the plan says they're going to turn out
so you got to keep that kind of
sexual ball rolling to say the least it
is my pleasure to introduce Roger warden
unfortunately i guess i have to agree
that a financial planner is always get
it wrong because you never get it right
because you can't predict the future i
will admit to one stereotype and i'm
going to cover this because i just
realized it the collating you have two
handouts in front of you one relates to
this and then the other one is a bonus
if we ran out of time it's it's
information that i did on a presentation
a few months ago kind of recapping
what's gone on the past couple get a
couple years in the financial markets
and what the implication is but the the
admission I must make is I just realized
that this handout is not complete you'll
see slides that aren't in there so I
just talked to charity and if she had
your name on the list she's got your
contact information and i will email
those out to you so feel free to to make
notes on the other pages but you will
see things up here that are not in that
presentation so i apologize for that it
dr. frank is exactly right the whole
purpose of financial planning is too I
think raise awareness there is no
perfect answer and financial planning no
matter what age you're at and I don't
try to think of financial planning in
retirement or financial planning you
know when you're in your 20s or 30s or
40 the the world has changed so much
that the importance of financial
planning applies to everybody and so
that's kind of the the background that
I'll put behind the comments and
observations that I'll make in terms of
questions feel free to raise your hand
and interrupt me as we go through I
think we've got plenty of time if we
don't I may push a question off to the
to the end or to the side so appreciate
your indulgence with that what we're
talking about retirement facts just some
interesting information how the world
has changed with respect to retirement
what I see is the risks of retirement
planning regardless of where are you
approaching it from what are the risk to
be aware of
it's the awareness of these risks that I
think make the biggest difference in
whether you get surprised or not because
it's the lack of awareness it causes
problems down the road the question we
get asked a lot how much is enough do I
have enough to retire can I afford to
retire am i okay am I going to run out
of money the past two years the crisis
of 2008 did nothing to help answer that
question the right way and quite frankly
it's challenged a lot of about how
financial planners look at trying to
help answer that question of how much is
enough asset allocation will touch on
the importance of thinking properly
about asset allocation and not getting
caught up with some of the rules of
thumb that you might hear that in and of
themselves aren't bad they just may not
be right I like thinking about the magic
five years that's kind of if you get as
you're approaching retirement and into
retirement there's like a 10-year window
five years before or five years after if
you get your decisions made correctly
for you in that period of time you're
pretty well set up to do well in
retirement and then i have what i call
my simple guide to retirement planning
contrary to what anybody tells you
retirement planning in and of itself
should not be that difficult but the
financial services industry has done a
tremendous has done a tremendous job of
making it seem more complicated than it
is I've one of the best things I found
was this XM satellite radio I didn't
know that existed until I went off my
wife and I went to Zion National Park
and we ended up with a rental car that
had it I was just amazed that you could
get radio out in the middle of this
desolate National Park so when I bought
a car and it had it I decided to keep it
will also found that it has a CNBC in a
bloomberg channel on it so I can't help
myself I listened to it I'm just amazed
at how many different reasons during the
course of an eight-hour day that
somebody can come up with as to why the
market is up by the market's down it's
Qaddafi it's Charlie Sheen its oil it's
I mean after a while you just have to
turn it off and back when it was really
bad in 2008 you know was they were they
were live broadcasting on sunday nights
talking about what's going on in Asia
because we
the world was going to end and that's
kind of the topic in the second round if
we get to it I think maybe we were close
but I think we're okay now so we'll
leave that just hanging out there the
retirement environment that we're in now
is colored by these factors that we
didn't have before longevity the fact
that demographically baby boomers are
now boomed this is it I think it might
have been mentioned in the last session
2011 baby boomers turn the first baby
boomers turned 65 and then you know
every 8 seconds there's a new baby
boomer turning 65 so I did this a few
years ago and at that time they were
turning 60 or 62 I forget what I used is
the the magic point 62 I said now that
could apply for early social security or
something so I found you know so who are
baby boomers that returning 65 this year
and you know it's kind of kind of
surprising to think this is just the
leading wave of who's turning 65 and and
this massive wave is really going to
color the conversation about how we as a
country deal with some of these issues
but it highlights the point that a lot
of us have to start thinking about you
know what is retirement the number of
individuals who are in this age that we
normally think of as retirement and I'll
say I don't have a good age for
retirement retirement so whenever you
want it to be and I think financial
planning ought to provide you with the
freedom to choose when that is 65 is
just what society and social security of
have forced us into talking about so
it's a it's a number it's a it's an age
that we use and the facts are there are
more and more people following falling
into that that that time frame I just
like this chart this is a chart from a
firm that that does global investing and
and what it does is it puts the world
into patterns by the investable
capitalization of that particular
country so as you would imagine as you
would imagine us is the big gorilla in
the room
and what's always surprising and this is
about this is a year old China that we
we're so influenced by is still a
relatively small player in the
investable universe but the point is if
we had done this 20 years ago the United
States would have been much bigger and
there would have been very little going
on in here you would not have seen
Brazil you would not have seen China you
would not have seen india the the world
is changing and globalization is going
to color any conversation we have about
retirement planning not going to talk
about that but I think it's a
fascinating area for for future
discussion several studies that I when I
go out research this say that as a as a
group we're less and less confident
about our ability to retire so when
these surveys are done and these go
through 2010 what you find is retiree
competence in terms of being able to
retire continues to shrink you know
going from very confident about
retirement from in the 40s back in in
the last bull market of the stock market
down to around twenty percent people are
not very comfortable that they're doing
what they need to do or are able to do
what they need to do about retirement I
thought this was interesting the the
expectation as we go from back in
nineteen ninety 12 2010 the expectation
of continuing to work until 70 or older
continues to increase that's a function
of a number of things when people feel
more able to work later they want to
work later and I think there's just a
financial need to work later I'm going
to skip through some of these to dr.
Frank's point when you do the surveys
most people do not try to calculate how
much money they need to retire they
don't think through the issues that
we're talking about today and I think
that's a mistake because you're not
going to get a right answer i'll admit
that up front but at least you'll get an
answer and you'll have an awareness of
perhaps gaps in your
retirement plan and a lot of this is not
all financial all the things you're
talking about here family dynamics
estate planning where you're going to
live all of these things come into the
the calculus of coming up with a a
successful retirement it's not just all
money but money helps lubricate some of
those other decisions so we want to talk
about it when people have a better
awareness of how much they need to
retire obviously if they think about it
and they tend to end up with a higher
number which tells me that just that
awareness makes you aware of the reality
that it probably takes more to retire
financially than intuitively you might
like that number to be and so sometimes
people avoid financial planning because
they just don't want to get the result
but I think that's a false psychic
savings workers who have done a
calculation or more confident make sense
you've got a better handle on am I
headed in the right direction but it's
it's like doing your will and exercising
it's difficult to do unless somebody
kind of that puts it yes sir net worth
it well this is this is retirement needs
that the respondent said was needed in
other survey results you're you're
typically looking to avoid say personal
residence or non investable assets so
it's not net worth its investable
expendable assets now what they don't
fool yourself into thinking nobody does
it anymore they used to think because
they had rising real estate values that
they had a comfortable retirement coming
to them but nobody nobody makes that
assumption anymore so there are some
common responses when you have a
discussion with somebody about the
numbers aren't looking right what what
should i do so you'll hear these
responses were
longer spend less in retirement or
downsized Mackenzie did a study I think
this is in 2009 and what they found was
the expectations pre-retirees have about
what they're going to be able to do
don't match up with reality a full forty
percent of retirees forced to stop
working earlier than they plan largely
because of things that they could not
control so the idea of working longer
some people say I'm just going to work
till I die that's my retirement plan
sometimes you can't do that so you don't
want to leave that as the as the only
fallback position you have under
estimating retirement needs I was
meeting with a client yesterday and
longtime client and they finally came in
and said you know what we just need to
take more money out you know can we do
that and they had a cushion built up and
we we said that and I told him I was
doing this and today and they said so
you're going to use us an example of
somebody who just spends too much money
i said no i mean you're you're you're
okay but it's a common situation to get
into where you go into retirement or you
stop your regular income flows and don't
know how much you really need to to
maintain the lifestyle that you want to
maintain the difficulty is when you get
into retirement it's sometimes hard to
spend less like you'll hear these rules
of thumb about you're going to spend a
certain percentage of your
pre-retirement income things like health
care relocation family needs really get
in the way of using those rules of thumb
and what the survey shows was that a
large number of the respondents had
underestimated what they found their
retirement spending needs to be I'm not
a big fan of budgets I don't think you
should budget but thinking about at
least the big buckets of what you want
to be able to spend comfortably in
retirement is a wise thing to do
downsize this used to be a big one we're
going to take our our real estate that
we've had value in cell it take
portion of it by something smaller never
seems to happen it's almost even if you
want to downsize size-wise you end up
spending the same amount of money and so
you just don't you just don't see this
as being an answer to the problem of you
know how do you find some margin in your
retirement planning calculation I like
to think about these is you know the
critical things that kind of bring this
complex topic into focus all right so
what I talk about our five retirement
risks and then these other numbers will
become obvious as we go through them but
the five retirement risks longevity
inflation excess withdrawals being too
safe this is that asset allocation
conversation and then healthcare risk
concerns so these are the risks that can
destroy a retirement plan quite frankly
even if you plan for it but awareness of
what these risks can mean can set you up
to be able to avoid some of least the
obvious mistakes longevity for I'm sorry
no I was just saying considering the
implication of these risks can set you
up for at least avoiding the avoidable
portion of the wrist but oh sure
longevity inflation excess withdrawals
being too safe and health care concerns
and we'll go through each one of these
in order
holdings in surprise at longevity is
increased but the degree to which it has
increased has been pretty dramatic and
that there was probably conversation
about that in the last session what I
like to focus on though is what's that
implication for retirement planning it
used to be you didn't have to plan for a
long retirement the lack of longevity
took care of that for better or worse
but what we're finding now and I'll show
this to different ways and I'm going to
I'll jump over to the to the graph
because I think it's easier to see this
what this is saying is for a couple if
you have a man and woman who are both 65
from an actuarial standpoint these are
the percentages that either the man or
the woman or at least one of them the
probability that they'll be alive to 72
to these ages here so 80 85 90 95 so
you've got a twenty-five percent chance
that at least one of those 65 year olds
will live to age 96 we didn't have that
before that was not a factor that had to
be considered from a financial planning
standpoint so for professionals in the
planning business the implication is
yeah I could say I'm going to build a
plan or an expectation to this fifty
percent probability that you know we're
going to live somewhere in the late 80s
but the reality is we need to be pushing
it out into the mid 90s because it
doesn't if you're if you're working for
a man and a woman a spouse and a husband
you know husband and a wife you don't
want it to work for only one of them you
want it to work for both of them so the
awareness of that reality is one of the
big changes that we didn't have you know
even ten years ago and I think this will
only get
to be a bigger issue as healthcare
changes you know make that number go out
more so that's where the 30 come comes
from you want to plan with a 30 year
time horizon in terms of retirement
using that 65-year retirement age you
ought to plan on being able to
financially make it out to age 95 used
to be there was also a financial
planning objective you know you dare so
how much do you want to leave for the
next generation for the kids the
response to that one just isn't the same
as it used to be it's like as long as I
can get through you to my retirement the
kids can take care of themselves I just
don't want to leave them a burden and
you know that that's enough so that's
part of this longevity situation as well
inflation risk I'm sorry Oh we'll come
back to that one that relates to health
care costs so this is just going to
those those numbers that we need to know
we've got five retirement risks we've
got a 30 year time horizon that we want
to plan for and then we'll we'll work
our way down to the other numbers so
risk number two as it plays into this
because of the longevity is inflation
inflation used to not be as big of a
concern because we didn't have to worry
about a long retirement so these are
these are related in that if you've got
to make a retirement plan last for 30
years you can't ignore the effects of
inflation so you can look at it a couple
different ways $100,000 today with a
three percent inflation factor your
purchasing power after 20 years almost
cuts in half what that hundred thousand
dollars is is able to buy for you so you
can't take a Cavalier approach and as
long as you're creating say that were
the right level of income so you're
creating that level of income if you
don't have any provision for growth of
the underlying asset that's creating
that in
and you just keep creating that same
nominal amount of a hundred thousand
dollars a year at some point it's not
going to be enough to maintain the
lifestyle that you're planning for just
another way to look at it in terms of
dollars hundred thousand dollars after
30 years forty thousand dollars now
right now inflation is pretty nice CPI
you know is less than three percent but
the long-term average is three percent
and so I think that's a fair number to
use so it's sometimes easier to think
about in terms of an example something
everybody deals with in 1979 which was
31 years ago postage stamp was fifteen
cents in 2010 44 cents annual increase
of three-point-five percent roughly
matches that that increase in inflation
inflation xin cities you don't know
where it's going to pop up but it's
pretty safe to say it's going to be
popping up in things that you need to
spend in retirement and we'll talk about
it you know briefly in a little while in
certain areas like health care it's even
worse so at a minimum we need to be
taking into account some level of
inflation now from an investment
standpoint we try to think about returns
from a real return standpoint and what
we mean by real return over long periods
of time stock market roughly averages
around nine and a half to ten percent
bonds roughly around five point seven
percent but when you lay on top of that
this three percent inflation factor
reduces your return fairly dramatically
late taxes on top of that which is
different for everybody even worse and
if you're trying to be too safe and
you're here in cash you're actually
ending up with negative real return so
you can't stay ahead of that inflation
burden that's going to insidiously start
working its way into your retirement
budget so inflation has a real impact on
on how we should think about positioning
for retirement so just keep that in mind
all right the overspending the way we
think about overspending is really
taking too much out of the nest egg or
excess withdrawals it's how much can you
take out without imperiling the
longevity of the portfolio and so it is
that how much is enough question does
flipped around well how much can I take
out and if the amount i can take out is
enough then I've got enough if it's not
well I don't have enough when you ask
this question and in surveys that people
tend not to get this one right and and
some of this I say goes back to when we
started when i started with Tarpley and
Underwood and in this profession in 1998
it's a terrible time to start in this
profession the stock market was going up
but when you would come out and say you
know what you need a balanced portfolio
of stocks and bonds and all this and
there would go are you crazy SP is going
up twenty-five percent I can go up
twenty-five percent a year take out ten
percent a year I'll never run out of
money and that works fine until you know
the market crashes so there's a reason
why you think about what the right
withdrawal rate is and it's not just the
return on the portfolio it's something
else so what you're looking for is a
sustainable withdrawal rate and
sustainable means that given the
longevity that we're concerned about you
position assets in such a way that if
you take out a certain amount it's going
to last for the period of time that you
need so we're thinking in terms of a
long period of time 30 years so what you
can look at is different allocations
mixes of stocks and bonds and what's a
supportable withdrawal rate and you'll
see different i got have different
versions of this so don't get too don't
get too caught up on the the allocation
look for the theme and the theme is you
can't necessarily be as safe as you
would like to be in positioning your
investments and you can't have a
withdrawal rate that is unsustainable
over a long period of time and the
reason you can't just say if I'm earning
ten percent I can take out ten percent
I'll be okay you know in a no tax world
even let's let's ignore that is the
problem is timing it's when do you get
those returns because they do not come
in a straight line so these were the
actual return experience if you retired
in with five hundred thousand dollars in
1973 and this is one of the worst
periods of stock market returns that we
had the the high inflation period of the
70's and into the early 80s and so what
would happen is those those negative
return results that you had early on
kept the portfolio from being able to
maintain itself and eventually the
portfolio just would collapse in on
itself but if you just took that
sequence of returns and flip them around
you end up with a much different picture
and the problem is you don't know when
returns are going to to show themselves
positive or negative you have to take a
position that i'm going to structure a
withdrawal plan and i'm going to
structure the allocation so i can deal
with both it's a it's kind of walking
the middle of the road answer to try to
deal with uncertainty
no no this is this is showing its taking
the actual returns that occurred over
this period of time and flipping the
order of them to just show that if you
had been unlucky enough to in to retire
at a period of time that you've got a
negative return experience versus
somebody who is lucky enough to retire
when you've got a positive return
experience it's almost a bad luck of the
draw quite frankly but you can mitigate
being a victim of that by taking some of
these conservative measures like keeping
a reasonable withdrawal rate what this
is showing is the the probability of
success with different withdrawal rates
same at the same allocation but
different withdrawal rates and what you
see is as you increase even by 1% that
withdrawal rate your probability of
having a portfolio last over the entire
lifetime of a retirement decreases
dramatically the difference between four
percent and eight percent quite frankly
means a high likelihood of retiring
successfully versus almost a a an
extremely unlikely opportunity to retire
successfully yes sir
well the idea is that when you're
looking at these probabilities you're
using monte carlo simulation to simulate
a range of those different returns that
could happen if we say you want to make
it out to 30 years say it 65 you want to
make it out to 95 the likelihood of
having a successful outcome if you have
a higher level of withdrawal drop
significantly if you increase that
withdrawal rate probabilities that's
correct so that's where I come up with
this 4.25 they're actually it's it's
kind of a to say 4.25 is the magic
percentage for a withdrawal rate it
almost gets into that rule of thumb area
if you want to simplify it's a five
percent for every million dollars fifty
thousand dollars of withdrawal is
probably supportable over a reasonably
long period of time 4.25 comes from some
academic work by done by a gentleman
named Bill Bergen who did a lot of
testing to come up with with that 4.25
and you find in different scenarios
trying at different ways and watching it
over time it's not a bad it's not a bad
rule of thumb to use so that's where the
4.25 comes from that's a percentage that
you should be able to take off of a
diversified nest egg and have it last
for this 30-year period of time that
we're trying to try to target for
well the assumption here is that you're
just not running out of money i mean the
probability is a failure being below
zero so you're not targeting anything
left over you're targeting not to have
zero you can always you can complicate
the planning scenario by saying I don't
want to target zero I want to target
something above that and adjust your
adjust your assumptions risk for being
too safe this is the asset allocation
discussion if you lay on top of that
withdrawal rate how you invest you start
getting different views of that
probability of success again that start
getting you to where you need to be
thinking about how do you position your
nest egg in retirement and I'd argue
this is ultimately for all the smoke and
mirrors at the financial services world
likes to to put on it this is kind of
the crux of what you're trying to get at
what's the right amount that I can take
out and how should I position by my
portfolio the easy thing to see I think
is if you start getting that withdrawal
rate certainly too much above this five
percent level you can't just sit in a
all bond portfolio you've got to have
some exposure to assets that will stay
ahead of inflation stocks and there's a
simplified example you can obviously
break this up into a bunch of different
ways but if we just look at stocks and
bonds your likelihood of success as you
have a higher withdrawal rate definitely
increases as you start adding some stock
exposure now interestingly enough you
can see there's kind of a point of
diminishing returns we're a hundred
percent stocks and the lowest withdrawal
rate is actually less than seventy-five
percent stocks and twenty-five percent
bonds where it's ninety two percent
that's the diversification impact that
comes from not having all of your eggs
in one basket but the point
is you can't be too safe and have a
reasonable level of being able to last
for that that long retirement period
with a reasonable withdrawal rate that
makes sense because any any
annuitization element of the or even
potential annuitization element of a
portfolio is really the is is a bond
proxy think of it that way the crap
portion is the stock portion the TI
double eight and it can vary is how you
get it out of there is really the bond
portion of the portfolio yes sir no no
no you don't yeah but but what I'm
saying is the structure of the
investments that underlie that you can
have different distribution options
there there there more bond like fixed
income like than they are stock like
history when you look back and say what
were the sustainable withdrawal rates
for the different levels of allocation
so two percent 4% 68 so on you actually
do have periods of time and you can see
the periods that that were we're looking
at you do have periods of time 30 year
periods of time where you could have a
relatively high withdrawal rate the the
problem is it's the probabilities just
not going to be high enough that you're
going to be lucky enough to be retiring
in advance of one of the
bull market periods that would allow you
to have that high withdrawal rate what's
the downside of a low withdrawal rate
you might end up with too much money
when you die and that's not something
you necessarily target for but it's
better than the alternative okay yes so
reason it's a reasonable proxy these are
going to be I believe this one's looking
at no no the the stock proxy here I'm
almost certain is SP 500 and the bond
proxy is almost certainly t-bills or not
t-bills but Treasury bonds it but what
you find is if you complicate try to
complicate it by putting in different
asset classes and different types of
bonds you tend to come up with the same
relative answer yes sir
no I can say these these are index
numbers so that's a very important point
i'll put my bias out there my my my bias
is that you get a better investment
experience by keeping your expenses low
which pushes me to always say a passive
investment approach is better than an
active expensive investment approach
because if these are index returns and
the studies and history show that active
management that adds expense doesn't
improve the performance all this does is
shift everything down right but but i
guarantee i could find plenty of people
standing up right now who would say
differently because they do have a bias
so right in that in that other
presentation I've got some the
statistics that show what percentage of
active managers beat their benchmark and
you know it's it's a low percentage
relative to what the marketing would
tell you yes sir
yeah the one of the best things I read
recently by a sa colleague he's in the
same same he's an advisor with a firm
they use all all passive or index
approaches and he the book just came out
I think it's called searching for alpha
which is over performance and he has
kind of a Q&A in there and he responds
to the question is what about Warren
Buffett and his response is if you get
up in the morning and look in the mirror
and you see Warren Buffett you do
whatever you want otherwise I recommend
you use index funds and taking that that
that stamp analogy just a little bit
farther to compare it to risk assets not
recommending everything in risk assets
but we sometimes lose a perspective the
sp500 in 1979 was at 107 that at
December 31 it was 1258 so that period
of time where we had the the inflation
or one hundred and ninety-three percent
of increase in cost we had a thousand
seventy six percent increase in the risk
asset index over that same period of
time it's this is the reason why you and
i like to say i'm not i'm not saying you
need to have a one hundred percent in
stocks i'm not going anywhere near there
but the point is you can't stay ahead of
this by staying in all assets that are
completely risk-free particularly now
just when fixed-income assets or running
such a glow yield so 6040 this is this
is definitely art not science but 6040
is a split between stocks and bonds and
you could make that 5050 and I wouldn't
I wouldn't you know have a problem with
that that says that type of mix is what
supports
this kind of withdrawal over a 30 year
time frame if you start getting safer
with this you start impacting your
ability to support that or to support
that one on something probably going to
have to give yes sir no because the the
longevity is is less at that point then
for a 60 year old so there is some there
is some reason to get more conservative
in a portfolio because you can afford to
get more conservative it doesn't have to
last as long see the challenge we we
have is it we're trying to avoid the the
pain of the risk of volatility but we're
having to offset that with what I call
the pain of the risk of impoverishment
and it's real easy to avoid the risk of
the volatility of the stock market you
just stay out and then you feel good
when the stock market goes down you feel
a little bit bad when it goes up and
you're not there the this negative
experience of being impoverished
unfortunately happens over such a long
period of time it sneaks up on you and
so I'm you know always out there trying
to say I don't want you don't take more
risk than you have to and that's why you
have to do some you have to do some
planning to to try to know what the
right number for you is I say if Bill
Gates walked into my office and said hey
Roger you know heard about you over
there in Atlanta I'm out of the I'm not
going to give my money away but I've got
this 40 billion dollars you know I don't
need that much but what would i do what
should I do I wouldn't tell him that he
needs a 60-40 globally diversified
portfolio i tella put it all in t-bills
and pull out what you need you know you
don't need to take any risk most of us
don't have the latitude to take no risk
at all that's that's really the point
the awareness point that i'm coming at
and i'm going to say it's not a matter
of I don't know they're active is the
writer I think proactively rather than
reactively move it when you can afford
to move it and I I'll show you a
mathematical computation to try to help
answer that question but it I think it's
inaccurate to say that an asset
allocation today is good for the rest of
your life it does need to change and it
should be changing all variables being
equal it should be getting more
conservative over time that the the
fifth risk this health care costs this
is really those long-term care costs
once again ten years ago you didn't have
to worry about it fidelity did some work
to say that a couple retiring at 65 will
need 160 thousand dollars to supplement
Medicare and other out-of-pocket health
care costs a couple retiring at 60
should plan on 210,000 because they're
retiring pre-medical Medicare you know I
don't know what the right answer is in
terms of health care costs because one I
don't think it's very easy to project
what they're going to be and what the
rate of inflation is going to be I think
the the awareness point for this risk is
it's just going to be a reality that
health care costs can blow apart a
retirement budget and knowing that this
may surprise you on the tail end of a
retirement is is the point here the
numbers that i came up with came from
what the the cost of an average private
room long-term health care stay would be
in a Atlanta health care facility
because you've got 168 dollar per diem
rate
the average period in a in a long-term
care facility two point four years and
365 days gets you to this 147,000 168 so
of a husband and wife if one of them
requires long-term care and they stayed
for the average period of time that
would be the cost now how do you address
that cost well that's later on you can
either self-insured or you can look at
long-term care and long-term care
insurance is not cheap it's hard to pay
for because it's kind of like paying for
any other insurance that you may never
use and hope you don't use but if if
this is going to imperil the retirement
of the the second spouse it's something
at least to look at because that's where
the risk is if you have a husband and
wife you may be able to self-insure for
the first period of care and pay
privately for the care that's required
but it may reduce the resources
available for the surviving spouse and
that may not be the right the right
answer but i'm going to i'm gonna say
health care is just one of those areas
where nobody's got a good answer income
from how to project I I think there's a
change in financial planning that's
coming and unfortunately the technology
doesn't help us do this yet which is
thinking about phased retirement you
have a period of time where you're you
spend more money because you're healthy
and there are things you want to do and
you can then you go into a phase where
you just you've done what you wanted to
do you're not spending as much and then
there'll be a final phase where you're
spending more than you anticipated
because of health care costs problem is
trying to figure out where those break
points are or extremely difficult yes
I mean health care reform no that's the
problem it's changing I don't know what
the answer is I've heard since the the
Health Care Act was passed I've had been
in presentations with you know three
different consulting firms who at some
point in the presentation get to the
point go we don't know what this means
and I think anybody knows what it means
as to and see those discussions really
are talking about health care costs here
I'm kind of focusing on long-term care
costs which are a whole different animal
because this is not long-term care
nursing home care assisted living here
is not a part of the health care reform
discussion I don't think you know so I
this is one I just don't have an answer
for I can I can I can put my finance
accounting hat look at history and I can
come up with an answer in terms of what
I think is a reasonable way to approach
asset allocation I don't have a good
answer for this one other than to say
explore long-term care if you're
concerned about it don't be surprised by
the cost of it and it may be a decision
where you say you know we'll just assume
that risk but at least you know it's not
a surprise and sometimes you find
children are willing to pay a long-term
care premium expense because they don't
want to have to be concerned about the
possible risk of their parents needing
that care and not being able to afford
it so I think we'll see a lot of
different different dynamics going on as
we try
deal with this so a to the to the
implementation part of how to think
about some of these issues I've got a
this is my my quicken and dirty
retirement planning how do you do it and
this applies pre-retirement and near
round retirement post retirement you
find some of the variables you can't do
anything about so it's it's it's a more
of an exercise to see are you okay and
then trying to fix that can be could be
perhaps problematic but here's all
retire meant for my financial standpoint
comes down to be what cash flow what
income do you need what fixed cash flow
resources do you have available to meet
that need for most there will be some
gap that has to be met up by portfolio
withdrawals or nest egg withdrawals and
then you come up with the best way to to
access those withdrawals so keep it in
mind some of the math we were talking
about before if your pre-retirement
trying to think about okay how much I'm
going to spend in retirement I usually
find it's best to not use those rules of
thumb of some some fraction of your
expenses but go with what you have what
you're spending now and then make
adjustments for things that you can
reasonably project healthcare relocation
travel you know everybody has a
different set of goals and objectives I
have but you want to take those into
account you just don't want to assume
that they're going to happen because
because you want them to
so filling the gap like I say it comes
from your nest egg so i'm gonna i'm
going to skip past this and get to the
example if you've got a need of ten
thousand dollars and you've got three
thousand dollars of sources of income
wherever it's coming from rental income
pension income it's something that's
that's relatively fixed social security
and there's a whole level of debate and
i can't answer at Social Security going
to be here but I think it will be for
the foreseeable future but it gives you
a gap all right so a monthly gap of
seven thousand dollars is an annual need
of eighty-four thousand dollars to come
from the portfolio so if you think back
to our our four point two five percent
example what that would imply
mathematically is that you need a nest
egg and this is once again for a 30-year
retirement that is balance between
stocks and bonds of around little shy of
two million dollars to to meet that gap
that you need to generate what's not
coming from regular sources of income so
like I was saying you could get pretty
close by saying fifty thousand dollars
per million as well this becomes a
starting point to know whether any work
close to to generating enough income
because if you don't go through this
exercise you you you just don't have any
idea it's too hard to know what does it
take to generate this and if you think
back to the numbers of of what people
thought they needed to have in
retirement that if they did some
planning they ended up with a bigger
expectation here which leads to a
greater likelihood of success in either
saving forward or accumulating it so how
do you get this and somebody asked me a
question before the the session about I
think it was guaranteed growth annuities
and I don't actually know that
phraseology but there are
level of different types of annuities
out there to use to generate an income
stream my preference is this idea of
total return paycheck replacement and
all that means is you don't lock it up
in an annuity because of the the
downsides of an annuity the downside of
a total return paycheck replacement is
you don't have the certainty of an
annuity because as in very simple terms
an insurance company will take a lump
sum that you give them and give you an
income stream the downside to that the
guy just listed these the downside to
that is there may not be anything left
when you when you pass away and you're
not that the insurance company keeps
what's left once the money is in there
you lose the flexibility of doing other
things with it and if you look at
annuities and they have any level of
inflation adjustment in them can be
quite expensive in terms of how those
products or structured so it there is
just a a ton of people out there trying
to sell different flavors of annuities
when I think of annuitization a fixed
annuity is what we're talking about it's
the cleanest form of an annuity it's
very much like if you annuitize the TI
double a portion that's an income stream
that you can you can rely upon the other
annuities that you hear talked about
variable annuities equity indexed
annuities probably the the anything that
has a guarantee in it would not be the
type of annuity that I would recommend
you take a look at just because every
time I've looked at those the costs
embedded within these annuity products
are I would say a detriment to
successful retirement planning let me
back up what i mean by total return
paycheck replacement just means that if
you think about that you set up a
portfolio that's 5050
stocks and bonds over any period of time
you're going to generate some amount of
interest some amount of dividends and
over a reasonable period of time they'll
be some growth to the principal would
the idea is what's the right amount come
out of that safe whatever five percent
generates you have automatically come
out into wherever you want to spend from
so you're replacing a paycheck by having
an automatic income stream so you don't
have to think about it as you pull that
liquidity out obviously you've got to
replace that liquidity and the way you
replace that liquidity is just have a
discipline mechanism for for pulling out
of either the stock portion or the bond
portion to keep that allocation the way
it should be so if stocks have run up
and they're now 6040 and you need to
take liquidity out even if stocks are
still going up the discipline says sell
enough stocks to get you back to 5050
and and use that for your liquidity next
time you may be pulling it from bonds
but that keeps you from getting too out
of too emotional about what the markets
are doing in terms of how portfolio
performance is experiencing itself so i
find that for for these long periods of
time and still maintaining flexibility
this is the best way to set up that that
income stream and you can set it up so
it like i say it automatically direct
deposits just like a paycheck from
wherever you've got your your portfolio
set up this is
you can do you if you if you simply if
you simply look to rebalance back to
what allocation is the right allocation
you can do it yourself and if you use
now the simplify if you put everything
in certain types of in investments like
a you know a boundless to simplify a
balanced mutual fund and you can find
index-based balanced mutual funds if you
take money out of their kind of
automatically rebalances itself so
that's one way to do it now could you do
it cheaper because there's some costs to
having that balanced mutual fund yeah
you could but at some level you've just
got to be comfortable with how good are
you at being disciplined about doing
that yes sir is your villains
just attitude and then you come up with
the portion is your go out of your
portfolio investment they do you
consider the interest in dividends that
maybe your portfolio is putting on every
movement period here as part of the
number income or no that's where the
total return comes from total return is
the total return off that nest egg and
it's going to be interest it's going to
be dividends and it's going to be
appreciation over time hopefully so no
I'm thinking about things like rents
pensions Social Security not investment
income and that's where you try to
simplify it as much as you can because
it's easy to get lost in and you know
what what is this income what what's the
nature of it but I'm the interest
dividends and growth or the total return
component that i'm referring to and
depending on what cycle we're in those
proportions change right now interest is
relatively low you know at least for the
last two years the the appreciation
portion of the relatively high dividends
have been relatively high but that
concept changed if the numbers don't
work and this is what I'm you know
talking to somebody who you say 55 and
you know there are only so many things
you can do retiring later makes the
biggest impact if you've got time saving
more generating some income in
retirement or spending less and then
addressing the longevity issue I never
find anybody wants to take them but I
have had and it's always meant it's
never women
had a couple mins site you know what
you're not giving me enough to spend on
going out to 95 my family's never live
past 82 I'll sign something that says
you know use the assumption that i'm
going to die by you know 82 okay you
know but we get you but if we get there
you're still going to be mad if you're
still alive bro so here here's the
things to think about there are things
you can control and things you can
control in this whole dynamic of
financial planning if you can a role if
you've got the time you can control
savings you can control the asset
allocation you can control the
retirement Rawls you may or may not be
able to control the retirement income if
you have the ability through consulting
your part-time work to generate
additional income but what you can't
control and we spend so much time trying
to to control these life expectancy it
is going to be what it is and you can
control that on the margins but it's
going to be what it's going to be the
market we spend all this CNBC time
trying to figure out what the markets
going to do you don't know what the
market is going to do it i guess i
should nobody's asked about gold or
anything like that so i'll go ahead and
say what I finally taken my position
today when somebody asks about gold or
the you know end of the capitalist
system or you know why are you have
money in the stock market it's a rape
the game here's a deal capitalism either
works or it doesn't work and if you come
to the inclusion rightly or wrongly
works for you if capitalism is not where
you know the future lies you should not
be investing in the stock market you
should be investing in gold it bottled
water in land in firearms in anything
else that that addresses that scenario
but I think that's such a low
probability scenario that I think you're
giving up the returns that kappa
ie the stock market and the bond market
can offer in order to make a retirement
plan work so if you're going to it agree
that the world is not going to come to
an end and capitalism is not going to
completely collapse and fail well then
you're back to making decisions about
what you can control what you can
control and you can't control the market
you can't control inflation you may or
may not be able to control health care
costs I admitted I I don't have a good
answer for that one but don't spend a
lot of time trying to figure out what
the market is going to do or what
inflation because you'll never you'll
never know yes sir you think it's
reasonable to say over a log horizon you
can look for two percent above inflation
necessary or three percent but what
number you use as a planning level in if
if I had to say what's a 60-40 portfolio
going to do over a reasonable period of
time I think it's in the seven to eight
percent range before factoring in taxes
and inflation so that gives you to
roughly a real return of about three
percent so here's another thing for for
we don't think about it much but all of
the things we've talked about are much
easier if your financial situation is
simplified so if you can get to the
point where you have the minimum number
of account relationships that you can
possibly have one checking account one
taxable brokerage account because you
have to break it up individually his and
her IRAs his and her Roth IRAs if isn't
her SEP IRAs if you have those his or
her 401k or 403b s the minimum amount
that you can have makes all of this a
whole lot easier the other thing I would
say is things like individual stock
certificates and all that you want to
get those in a brokerage account you
don't want those sitting around it all
of those things that add complexity make
it harder to keep control of what's
really important so you know I just and
God
a bit if something were to happen to you
your family will be a lot less you know
negative about the whole experience kind
of figure out where everything is
because so many times I'll see
situations where somebody comes in and
they have seven different IRAs at seven
different brokerage firms and there's
just no reason to have that you know
find one that you like working with and
put everything there I touched on to
Burton I touched on diversification in
in my mind simplify diversification
means you've got large and small US
stocks you have US bonds you have
international stocks and you have cash
you can accomplish some of these or all
of these in in one fund if you want to
to aggregate it that way take some of
the fun out of it but you can do that
you you can add other asset classes and
they may help it's real hard to quantify
exactly how much adding some of these
more esoteric alternatives ads but cash
you always you always got to have
liquidity I mean if you look at at your
overall allocation you've got to have
some liquidity that's not cash for
trading in and out purposes that's cash
for liquidity purposes so I pulled this
off just this morning a Smart Money
Magazine they've got these different
portfolios and you know this would fit a
50-percent stock thirty percent bond ten
percent alternative and that's probably
going to be something like a real estate
investable real estate you know a REIT
and then ten percent cash you can make
it fifty five percent stocks five
percent cash you can make it zero
alternatives and put all that in bonds
there's no no magic to it the point is
it's not all in one basket it's not
lacking in diversification because if
you use those index funds or the
appropriate alternatives that are out
there in stocks bonds alternatives you
can get plenty of diversification
appropriate diversification pretty
easily and then expense
I'm just going to look at it because we
run out of time the the five years that
I was thinking about as best you can if
you've got time before retirement or
you're into retirement the most
important thing you can do I think
before retirement is test drive you know
think about what is what does retirement
what's going to look like financially
what's it going to look like from where
I'm going to be lifestyle how I spend my
time and then once you're into it
monitor those withdrawals the couple i
met with yesterday we we've done this
over time and it's the right way to do
it we've changed that withdrawal rate
because they went from pre-retirement
they sold a business or shut down a
business that they've retired and you
know what they were saying yesterday is
you know what we enjoy doing the things
we do and we're just spending more money
can we afford to take more money out
it's like yes we can now two years ago
when we had the same discussion when I
was having discussions with clients and
they would say he can I do this home
renovation can i buy this new car I
would say you know if it's discretionary
I'd hold off because we don't know
what's going on with the market right
now that's a part of monitoring
withdrawals right now it's different if
you've been furring off getting that car
doing that remodeling you know we built
that cushion back up that we might have
eaten down into and you can start doing
that again this is that proactive part
of it it's it's being aware of what's
involved in financial planning in
tracking what you've got now I'm not big
on I say I've got budget here I'm not
big on budgets I think of it as spending
plans how do you spend money i don't
really care about individual line items
I'll do it I'll do it myself my simple
budget is if you're not incurring debt
then your budget probably works you know
for somebody early in the process I say
you need to do this kind of planning to
develop a savings goal so you should be
saving and if you're not going into debt
you're doing okay doesn't matter how you
spend whatever is in between
and see let's say everything you know
things are going well this is this is
getting into to that idea okay you've
got more than enough what should you
think about doing doing things for for a
family 529s I think are a great tool for
for the next generation or the next
generation after that because you can do
that in a very gift tax estate tax
income tax efficient way and if you're
able to address philanthropic desires
these are things that people just tend
to miss using don't donating appreciated
securities if you've got appreciated
securities and even with what's going on
the past two years you know many people
do don't give cash give appreciated
securities donor advised funds I'm not a
big fan of private foundations that
that's that's more complication than
most people need you can accomplish the
same thing with the donor advised fund
which is just a vehicle for getting a
donation and then you can actually give
the money distribute the money on your
own schedule so things to think about in
terms of hey all the numbers work we've
got excess well what do we do because
like i said if you've got excess
actually the first thing you could think
about doing is reducing the risk of your
portfolio if you have more than you need
and you've got a 60-40 portfolio mix
maybe you can switch it to 40 60 if the
numbers still work for you then you can
start thinking about doing other things
dr. Frank mentioned this you know
encouraging family communication and
looking at these things early actually
talking to children about doing their
own financial planning makes it easier
to approach your own financial planning
because the issues that everybody deals
with are the same they just come at
different times and some of the biggest
challenges that we're seeing right now
our clients who are in a situation where
they're concerned about their parent
situation and they're dealing with their
children
and so the idea of having communication
about retirement makes all of this
easier for everybody and for whatever
reason that's something we don't like to
talk about in terms of you know telling
our family here's our situation here's
where things are but you're doing it
you're leaving a tremendous legacy if
for for that next generation if you go
through the process of communicating
about these issues like i said i'll send
this this is a part of what should have
been in the presentation these are just
some some books and a couple web
resources that i think are good the
aicpa actually has some pretty good
resources available to the public this
this financial decisions guide is
actually a end of like planning guide it
helps think through those ideas of okay
if I'm not here what would i'd like to
put down on paper for who I left behind
to know about and then this 360
financial literacy org is just kind of a
one-stop shop for for financial topics
oh there are plenty of things to draw
from that a bad mouth CNBC but there are
some good resources out there smart
money which is a part of the wall street
journal family along with pharons and
the like smart money i think is the best
of all of them in terms of personal
finance issues Barron's not so much wall
street journal is is probably next after
a smart money but i think they do a
pretty good job of covering some of
these topics in the appropriate level of
depth
it's a 520 I'm going to stop there and
take any questions that we haven't been
able to cover I was saved quickly
because we didn't didn't get to it I
touched on it briefly my idea of where
financial markets are now is I think
we'll find as more academic work is done
that 2008 and early 2009 were critical
in terms of whether of capitalism was
going to survive it did and I think it's
probably the better for it in terms of
what the future looks like but it was an
interesting time when you look at the
fundamentals now there's definitely a
recovery in place and I don't care what
happens to Qaddafi or what happens to in
the Middle East obviously you have to be
concerned about oil but the fundamental
recovery in the United States seems to
be pretty little a trench with the
example with the exception of two big
gorillas in the room unemployment and
housing and we've seen to be dealing
with the recovery with unemployment
still unusually high and housing just
going to be a long slow slog still
doesn't seem like it's going to cause
any any double dip because it can't go
any so with that cheery note I'll stop
there
oh he left us watch up here oh well it's
time to wrap it up folks by the way one
of the things we've done is I have a
10-page remember that my daughter's get
an attorney yet so the CPA gets doesn't
say what the assets are but it says
where everything in sight is right down
to the file drawers in the file folders
so if my wife and I aren't around my
children have a chance to find out what
the facts are and where they are
otherwise they'll be lost and I've been
doing that like 10 or 15 years at any
rate thank you I hope it's been helpful
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University